all right hallelujah the day has arrived
I feel like my entire life has been some
sort of version of Groundhog Day for the
past like eight months telling people
that this book is gonna come out going
Oh April 28th it's somewhere in the
future we started doing the pre-sale on
this thing in July I finished writing
the book literally gave my final
manuscript to my editor July 31st of
2019 then I did my August off-the-grid
edited it in the fall really haven't
touched it since Thanksgiving and then I
did do the audiobook right at the
beginning of quarantine so I had to
drive to Hollywood which is sort of a
dystopian future in and of itself it's
just like becoming such a craptastic
little area of Los Angeles and I did the
audiobook which I absolutely loved and
I'm thrilled to see that a ton of you
because shipping some people were
expecting it today but you know I don't
know if you heard about this coronavirus
thing some people are getting the book
actually tomorrow or the day after so a
ton of you were are getting the
audiobook I did do it I love doing it I
absolutely love doing the voiceover
being in the booth and I get to sort of
act out some of the stuff and do some
impressions and all that good stuff but
anyway today is April 28th don't burn
this book it is here it is real it is a
thing as of this moment I am a published
author I've given this thing everything
I got I think the message that I promote
in this book of thinking for yourself of
individual rights of states rights of
standing up to the mob of knowing what
you think and why you think it I think
these are the things that actually
matter and obviously I wrote this thing
well before coronavirus but I think
perhaps now more than ever
excuse me perhaps now more than ever
don't worry that wasn't corona related
I've just been doing a lot of talking
the last five days these are the ideas
that matter right like I think we're all
thinking about these things right now
states rights are suddenly being talked
about for the first time yeah I've been
babbling on about them for a couple
years on this show and some
conservatives and libertarians walks
talk about them but suddenly everyone in
the mainstream media is going oh do the
states have to open up one at a time and
what does that mean and can once
do one thing and once they do another I
think people are rethinking the Second
Amendment and that you should be able to
protect yourselves or the Fourth
Amendment the right to assemble which in
effect is suspended right now these are
all ideas I put in the book but more
than anything else for the ideas that I
lay out here and I talk about my
feelings on on abortion and taxes and
foreign policy and pretty much
everything you can think of
environmental policy everything it's not
that I'm trying to convince you that I
am absolutely right on all of these
things or that I'm writing some kind of
Bible here what I'm trying to write here
is or what I've written here is
guidelines to a flourishing positive
decent society that will allow as many
people to pursue their dreams as they
see fit and I'm thrilled that so many of
you I mean we've sold a gajillion copies
already so I'm just thrilled that so
many of you are digging what I'm doing
so ok so today we are doing a live
signing so I'm sign-in all these books I
got a gajillion books right here David
at some point I'm gonna ask you to get
the silver pen I will sign one copy with
the special silver pen and one person
it's like Willy Wonka one person will
get the special silver copy but I am
signing copies of don't burn this book
and you can get one of these copies if
you have not pre-ordered or maybe you
did pre-order already but you want to
get a copy for somebody else I'm signing
a gajillion books today a gajillion
bookplates gajillion people that's a lot
you can get your signed copy Act
premiere collectibles dot-com slash
Rubin the link is in the description and
if you do that you can also submit a
question for this live stream and by the
way in in about 10 minutes you may have
heard of this fella before Glenn Beck is
gonna join us and and a little later
right after that I believe then this
this small podcaster who I think is
gonna make it this Ben Shapiro fella is
gonna join us but in the meantime I'm
going to be answering your questions and
I'm sign-in books for you guys signing
them live I rested my hand last night so
you guys are gonna get the good
signature there will be plenty of those
I'm gonna sign a ton of books again it's
premier collectibles dot-com slash Rubin
we're crushing it right now on amazon
and barnesandnoble.com
and everywhere else and yeah I do feel
like in many ways my life led up to
today somehow it's a it's a weird thing
but here we are alright so I'm gonna
start answering some questions and as I
said we got Glenn back coming in a
little bit we got Ben Shapiro come a
little bit maybe some other surprise
guests you never know what's gonna
happen here at the Rubin report and I
will press it preface this all by saying
that every every bit of success that I
have and every bit of goodness is really
directly related to you guys you have
been there for me you have seen the
growth of this thing the adventure that
we've been on from being at different
networks and quitting several jobs and
letting go of salaries and health
insurance and eventually being fully
independent building a home studio and
starting locals calm so we could even
get off the pipes of YouTube and
Facebook and Twitter and everything else
I've put all of the things that I talk
about in this studio into action in my
real life and that's a direct result of
the support that you guys give us so I
beyond thank you there's not even
there's not even quite a word for it and
and I mentioned that by the way in the
acknowledgments of the book all right
I'm gonna sign one more right now and
then we're gonna get to some questions
I'm giving you a big D and a good R for
these signings I feel good about the
loop today you never know oh okay whoops
can you grab that for me
cly is gonna get it clack can you get
that pen for me that's the special
silver you got it come on now that's the
special silver pen one book only one I
signed six book plates Oh Clyde is
really trying quite if you get me that
pen that will seriously go viral
I signed six book plates yesterday with
the special silver pen much like Willy
Wonka and the golden ticket watch it's
just gonna magically appear in my hand
right now there we go okay I have the
silver pen one book and one book only
that I will sign here we'll have the
special silver
signature and perhaps you will get an
inner tour with billable impose and the
whole thing of the Rubin report studio
all right
premier collectibles dot-com slash Rubin
let's get right into the questions
William in North Bergen Jersey can you
wish my mom Liz a Happy Mother's Day I'm
getting her a signed copy as a present
Liz happy birthday you got a great kid
thank you for your support Liz I hope
you enjoy the book hope you have a
wonderful Mother's Day and thank you so
much
Collin in East Lansing Michigan what do
you feel the proper responses to the
widespread censorship happening across
social media is censorship the new
normal so look I unfortunately I do
think in many respects censorship is the
new normal if we just accept that
YouTube Twitter Facebook Google all of
the big boys that they're gonna do
certain things I'm not even saying it's
not in their right to do those things
and we know about algorithmic
manipulation we know for example I can
give you very basic examples on this
channel that you're watching this right
now the bigger the channel has gone the
fewer of my subscribers get notified of
our videos even though you've opted in
and clicked the bell and the whole thing
we know that they manipulate search
results we know that shadow banning
which is when people can't see people
they follow on Twitter we know that
that's actually part of the Twitter
Terms of Service I'm not making that up
google it google it well there you go we
know that they they hide certain posts
on Facebook if you are of a certain
political persuasion your posts get
taken down we know about the suspensions
and all of these things so is it the new
normal I would say if your answer is
solely that big tech is your only way of
accessing the Internet and everything
else then yes we are seriously screwed
and by the way you know if you thought
we were screwed before if you thought
there was a problem with big tech before
and and I should also say I don't hate
big tech in and of itself these giant
companies have have endless cascading
problems that I just don't think that
they're equipped to deal with I think
this is actually kind of why david was
able to beat Goliath right like Goliath
grew so big that it was actually you
could take him out with one little shot
from a slingshot and I think that's sort
of what these companies are they've
grown so big that they have so many
problems so many competing interests
then you inject social justice in it so
you're not even hiring your best
engineers and you have an ideology
that's very much anti-freedom
as a core piece of your ethos at your
companies you got a big problem so I
don't know that these things can be
fixed I don't want the government to fix
them by the way I mean in this by the
way is exactly where Tucker Carlson
just have a fundamental disagreement I
will be on Tucker Carlson tonight I
think at about 8:20 Eastern 5:20 Pacific
talking about don't burn this book he
wants government regulation I don't
because yes the Trump administration may
be more open to you know free speech at
the moment but let's say you get a lefty
government in there are they gonna be
for that you know and maybe the Trump
government isn't even for it idea put
aside Trump or the Democrats or anything
else
the idea that you would combine
government and and big tech you're just
gonna make a big problem even bigger
right too big to fail what did we do
when we had banks that were too big to
bill we got the government about and now
they're even bigger and they're too big
to fail so I think we have a huge
problem there what I really believe the
solution is is that competition for as
long as we're allowed to have
competition in this great country of
ours competition will be the thing that
gets us through this it's exactly why I
started locals calm which by the way we
did our round of fundraising in the
midst of coronavirus which was the most
insane time so we had documents out for
our investors as the markets were
absolutely tanking I'm thrilled and
proud to say that our investors came
through
we raised a nice chunk of change I don't
get a dime by the way I've put in money
and I've put in a lot of time we've
built an incredible team we've got team
in Europe we've got people in New York
we've got people in in California really
all over the place and we're building a
great product and we're what we're
building our digital homes or creators
and that's what we've built with Ruben
report.com and the iOS app and the
Android app and you should check it out
if you haven't been there and if you're
a creator and you want to own your stuff
if you want to have we don't want your
data we don't own your data or all of
the right things we've done as many of
them as possible so I do think
censorship is sort of the new normal
we're all trapped in our house right now
and if we thought there was a big
problem well now we got a bigger problem
because our only way to communicate is
through these pipes and I think we just
got to figure out how to how to keep
keep being nimble enough so that big
tech doesn't actually own us all right
Nicholas in North Plains Oregon asks
what are some ways we can make a real
impact on local policies here's a really
simple one that pretty much nobody does
know who your local representative is I
know who my local representative is I
don't want to say his name because I
don't need people showing up at my door
but I know where his office is about a
mile away from my house I've gone there
before you have much more chance of
changing things through your local
representative than you do through your
senator or certainly through the
president we seem to have this odd thing
in America where the presidency has
become such a cult of personality and
this isn't just Trump I mean it's well
before Trump that it's like oh the
president's supposed to fix everything
if the economy tanks it's the
president's fault if this happens it's
the president's fault the president did
this depressed the president's just
supposed to sign things into law and
kind of guide us as a nation the
president isn't supposed to be doing
anything so especially for those of you
that are Liberty minded and and you want
to care about your local community let's
say I give you just a great example the
Main Street that crosses my street so
the main intersection over here is a
serious mess like potholes and it's just
busted up old a street well the one the
other way is brand-new they finally
fixed it so what did we do we contacted
somebody in the local local community
government here and we're trying to find
out are they gonna fix that Street now
if you can't go to your local guy Who am
I gonna go to I'm gonna go to my senator
to see if they can do it you know like
really the Senators got bigger problems
so I think keeping as much as local as
possible that really is the thing and by
the way you know I talk so much about
states rights in this book and the
founding documents that they wanted the
founders wanted us to have different
laws and different policies different
policies I should say in each state
rights because what's good for
California isn't necessarily what's good
for Texas are good for Idaho and right
now people are talking about it cause of
coronavirus right Texas is gonna open up
in a couple days it doesn't look like
New York is gonna open up anytime soon
they have different problems and you
just have to hope that you've elected
some people that are that are pretty in
line with what your views are
I'm not doing a great job of that by the
way here in California because my mayor
is Eric Garcetti a progressive and my
governor is Gavin Newsom a progressive
so there you go all right I think we've
got Glenn Beck oh I'm gonna sign some
books that's what I'm doing here guys by
the way I'm signing books live I'm live
signing books right now is Glenn Beck
ready we've almost got Glenn we've got
Glenn all right I'm gonna sign this book
right there these are live signings all
right why don't we bring in Glenn Beck
he's somewhere in an undisclosed
location in a bunker somewhere where is
he let's talk to Glenn Beck Glenn are
you there
do we have yeah look I think I see him
we're gonna wait for some audio to kick
in
and I'm gonna keep going look he's
taking a seat all right I'm gonna keep
going while Glenn takes a seat
let's see this is Lauren in Cleveland
Tennessee and she says during this
quarantine we've seen how quickly people
are willing to give up their civil
liberties when they believe it's for
their safety
moving forward do you see this trend
continuing and if so you did not get any
questions from Dave so Glenn you are
alive
then can you hear me I'm live you are
alive my kids are using out let me get
my ears in get your ears in we saw you
signal my ears in here and I can't
figure out uh thankfully you are wearing
how are you I am I am just fine my
friend I'm glad that you're the first
person I'm bringing on for this thing
because I think our relationship is sort
of like exactly why I wrote this book
that this this thing that is not
supposed to exist it actually does exist
yeah people can't believe it
that we don't hate him I remember the
foot I remember the first time meeting
you
thinking this could go horribly horribly
awry and I thought I trusted you but I
had thought I'd trusted people before
and was always burned but you were you
were so honest you reminded me I don't
mean this as a slam you reminded me of
me when I was in my third I was just
like yeah but you know when I when I
didn't care what the answer was I just
really wanted the answer I knew what I
had been doing wasn't working wasn't
working and it didn't make sense and you
know you get everybody gets to a point
you're either afraid to explore it
because you know it's gonna radically
change everything in your life and you
are one of the few really brave people
that have have gone through it and I
admire you for it well listen I mean
bravery is sort of a funny thing because
when you're doing it I don't you know if
you were brave I don't know that you'd
do it you just sort of do it and then
you go oh I guess some people don't like
me now yeah but but here we are but
actually wasn't there a point in England
oh go ahead go ahead go ahead well I
thought I was gonna say isn't there yeah
I'm gonna shut up go ahead satellite
time love it yes this is satellite time
it ain't like staring at somebody four
feet in front of you I was gonna say
that I think could be interesting for us
to talk about a little bit because I'm
gonna do your show in a couple days to
talk about the book but just talking
about the writing process cuz I just had
you on to talk about your new book which
we're putting up this week
you've written so many books you've been
through this process so many times and
it's funny for me today because I've
wanted this thing out for so long and
I've never given birth and as far as I
know men can't give birth unless
something happened this morning but I
feel kind of like I gave birth today
like like this thing is now out of me
which is sort of an interesting spot yet
it's it's really weird especially if you
I mean I've written so many books and so
you're always in the process and I just
finished this is my last book but I just
finished and you have written it and
gone through it months before and
usually I'm on to the next thing and
it's hard cuz you're like okay I got to
put myself back in that mindset but it
is like giving birth and it's especially
something I haven't read your book yet
Dave I haven't gotten a copy of it I did
so I feel bad because I didn't you know
I know generally I sent you a very nice
inscription on that copy you don't have
right we're gonna get you a digital one
in the meantime
yeah no I'm sorry I would have read it I
would have read it beforehand because
I'm really looking forward to to seeing
what you have to say and seeing the
whole process so tell me if you will
just tell me some of the some of the
process that you went through well it
was interesting because I didn't know
how I was gonna deal with the discipline
part because you know like I can
interview people and I talked to the
camera and I'll do stand-up things that
are kind of like you just kind of do
them and you're in the moment and it's
live and that's it then you just let
them go and they they stand for what
they are or they're they're good or
they're bad whatever it is for this it
was like writing it's just like a whole
other process and I found every morning
I'd get up I take the dog out to pee I'd
have my coffee I'd go into the green
room which is where our guests you know
come to get makeup and all that stuff
and I don't really have an office here
unfortunately because so much of my
house is dedicated to the show but I'd
sit in there I'd closed the door and I
would just start so usually about 7:30
8:00 a.m. and my process was I could
write and write and write and write
until I could not think any more and
usually that would be at about 2 or 3
o'clock and David David would sometimes
open the door and literally like I was
in prison solitary confinement he'd
slide a plate of food in he wouldn't
even say a word to me there just be a
sandwich or some eggs or something and
maybe I'd eat it maybe I wouldn't but if
I was in the mode I can just go and then
the second the mode breaks like the
second I would hit the wall I never had
like the five hours everyone talking
about like sit staring at a screen I
never had that if I if I got to where I
was no I was I was done
yeah I I my problem is I overwrite and
then it's the editors that are like oh
dear God what do we cut because I
usually write em a 80,000 words and and
they just just looking what to cut cuz
once i start vomiting into it it just
all comes out and I usually get I
usually get whole chunks that I'm like
okay let's save that for another
separate thing but I don't you know I
always write from the ending I know
where I want to end I know what my point
is and then I know where I'm gonna start
and then I just start vomiting and it's
really an interesting thing cuz it'll
take you different places if you write
it like you write it I think I write it
the same way it'll take you different
places that you didn't really expect cuz
you're you're you're processing all of
the information that you have but then
when it's coming in you're like well
wait a minute I and you're just thinking
things through it's it's an interesting
process because it's the only one that
you do and that I do that you can
actually spend time on that's actually
super interesting to me how processes
are similar and different so I this at
the beginning of the book when I got the
deal on the deal that I actually signed
the title of the book was why I left the
left and I started writing that book for
about three weeks and then I realized I
was like I don't want to write a book
about what I'm against I want to write a
book about what I'm for so the the
entire genesis of the book changed but
it's also interesting that you said that
you're that you know the ending because
as I got towards the ending I realized I
wanted a different ending I don't want
to give the ending away and I definitely
want you to read it before we before we
do our sit down but I didn't know I
could feel it and as I got towards the
end I was like ah I don't know what's
happening here because this is actually
where I'm at now and you you also you
know when you when you're really going
through your thoughts and really making
sure this is truly what I believe about
these issues it's that just in and of
itself changes you so I felt like I was
sort of a
in person by the time I got to the end
and then where I started to
I think that's really I mean those are
the important books Dave you know that
the my best-selling book was a common
sense I think we sold two million copies
of common sense and I remember I was
going to just dump it I was just gonna
dump it online anonymous because I was
so afraid of what was said in it and
because I really I started writing it on
vacation and I was reading it to my kids
and my wife and I'm like I don't know if
I have the guts to say this stuff and as
I just started going and going I didn't
know where that was gonna end but it was
just putting together all of this stuff
in my head that I thought was a real
problem that somebody needed to say it
and you know when you're when you're
approaching it and it's really
soul-searching and you realize that's
not what I want to say you're not doing
it for
it's not a calculation on where is yeah
country going to be was you're just
really focusing those are the important
books and that's yeah obviously what
you're doing so so let me ask you
something so as a guy that's written all
these books done all this stuff I think
the real sort of core of this is that I
want people to stand up for what they
believe in even if it's different than
what I believe in I I lay out all my
political ideals here and you're gonna
disagree with some of them and as I said
to you and I interviewed you just a
couple days ago I hope that we'll focus
on our differences when we talk about my
book because so that's a beautiful give
me one that we just wrong so what you
think we're gonna disagree on well for
sure I mean and this is this is the big
one for all my conservative friends I am
still what I would say is but grudgingly
pro-choice and that is the argument that
I lay out there I talk about a 12-week
cutoff and then there's a couple a
couple exceptions related to them the
mother's health and the rest of it but I
know that this is the one that for my
conservative audience that they're
really not gonna be happy with me most
of the other stuff where we disagree I
mean you and I pretty much take a
libertarian approach on things so it's
like you know we could Whittle them into
almost nothing but I think that that one
problem so will be the big one
so can I tell you in some ways I'm brie
grudgingly pro-life I don't like that
was lives yeah I I don't like missing in
people's lives you know when it's at the
cell state its potential life you know
is it life when does it become a child I
don't know I don't think any of us are
gonna know I don't want to insert myself
into your situation where you know
you've got a girl who is in a abusive
you know relationship with the father
and if and the mom and if they find out
that she is gonna be destroyed you know
all that stuff I don't want to get in
any of that and so I'm kind of I I
insert myself because I feel like I have
a moral responsibility but I don't want
to sit there and pound anybody who's had
an abortion or is thinking about a boy
unless you're like the baby milk kind of
people you know unless you're they
celebrate your abortion that's that's
obscene that's just obscene so I don't
think we actually differ all that much
yeah all right well listen you're gonna
read the book and we'll find out what
those parts are but but even the way you
laid that out I've never heard any of my
my pro-choice friends say burger oh
sorry my pro-life friends Sabra
grudgingly pro-life so that that is sort
of interesting and I think that that's
probably because you lie more on the
libertarian part of this where you're
still even though you want to protect
that life you still are so oh I don't
want the government involved that that's
where the begrudging part comes in and
I'm just coming at it from a slightly
different perspective but again that's
that's a beautiful thing when we can
Whittle it down to that yeah and I think
that it's it's also Dave part of it is
and I know you're like this
I hate my job in some ways because it
requires me to go into absolutes or to
judge you know this person is wrong this
person is right and the more I learn
about people the more I learn that if
you really knew what was going on in
their life you would understand a lot
more you may not agree with them but you
would have much more empathy you know
except for the despicable people that
that really are they don't think about
anything they're just are doing it for
greed or fame or whatever and that's a
different story but I don't know who
those people are
I can guess but I don't know and and so
I hate this this thing to where you know
its social justice there is no such
thing as social justice there is God's
justice was just perfect and then
there's man's justice which is as good
as we can get it but we're all flawed
there's no such thing as being able to
balance the scales and that's the
hardest thing and people just like no
we've got that person's wrong we got to
take all that stuff give it over to that
person good god you're only making
things worse what are you saying that
with all of our political acumen and and
all of the thinking when I listen to all
this you're saying that you and I
couldn't write a document that would be
perfect for all people is that what
you're saying because this changes I
don't have that weird my second edition
of the book I'm very different
hey I go solar I got one more for you
and then we got your Pierrot in a minute
and I know you got it you got to work
over there too are you in this moment
are you at this moment because of
coronavirus because of the way people
are thinking about things differently
are you actually more hopeful right now
for the ideas that we care about then
you have been in the past and have you
seen moments like this come and go
because right now I I genuinely am
seeing a really nice moment for us if
people keep their heads on straight but
I suspect it's not the first time it's
happened and it doesn't always stick
we got about a minute so first of all
you look at September 11th it's ticked
you know how long did that stick it
didn't stick around very long
you know time times of crisis come and
we pull together I've never seen
anything like this and that's why it
concerns me so much you know the the the
Socialists are after and the
environmentalists are after shutting the
economy of the world down like this and
then reshaping it and when you're
talking about universal basic income and
you know modern monetary policy I I'm
not sure Dave that that doesn't sound
very good to a lot of people because
when we start to really see the effects
of this and start to put this economy
back together it's gonna be harder than
we thought I I think and they're gonna
be people that are really angling to be
able to split us apart again and play
you know all of the on all of the
differences we really have to come
together as united we stand you know e
pluribus unum and and say look we're
going to disagree on a ton of things ton
of things but we have basic principles
of human decency in common and if we can
just recognize that there is no greater
mission statement we've never fulfilled
it and if we did we should pat ourselves
on the back and go on and do another
mission statement but there's never been
a mission statement greater than all men
are created equal none ever and we need
to just buckle down and look at all men
are created equal and endowed by their
creator with certain rights and protect
those rights if we can just agree on
that we can live and let live on so many
other things
well back I know at least the two of us
are agreed on that I thank you for
taking some time this morning and I just
want to say now that I got this by gosh
so no I'm just I'm just thrilled to be
on this adventure with you you you've
been a friend and an ally and I love
working with you guys at the blaze and
let's fix this thing I have nothing
better to do
right Dave please make sure you get me a
copy all right I'll just buy it
I don't mind I'll get a digital copy
myself it out to you already but well
you know what here let's we're just
gonna oh we sent to Tyler it's not
entitled
that's perfect yeah it's sitting there
I'll buy it on Amazon today and I'll
read it before we talk again thank you
so much thanks my friend be good
all right
alright thanks to Glen his copy is
sitting Tyler's the CEO of the blaze
he's a great guy it's sitting in Tyler's
office Tyler if you're watching this can
you drive over there or would you get
arrested I don't know all right
I'm told we have been Shapiro on the
line Ben Shapiro are you there
I believe we have been Shapiro
I'm gonna keep signing books while we
get Shapiro he's coming I could see
something happening on the screen over
there why name Reuben Ben Shapiro what
are you doing here well Ben shouldn't
you be out snitching on neighbors or
something you're just sitting at home
just waiting for people to call you on
skype yeah well you know I'm one of the
members of the media League so I get to
sit here and say that the economy should
remain closed and keep my job so I know
about you but I'm pretty comfortable I
mean like look I've got my church I'll
poster everything's good everything's
good - how's all the book stuff going
don't burn this book buy a broom and go
buy it today it is good it is a good
book ah yeah you know that that perfect
inflection and speed with which you
speak it has such a it has such a smooth
move across across the Internet
yeah things are good I mean the book is
selling like crazy and I was just
talking to Glenn Beck and I was saying
how you know this is my first one of
these and it's weird because you it's
like you want this thing out for so long
and I finished it last summer and I
actually I feel like I gave birth this
morning and as you no man can give birth
now so I'm feeling pretty good about
things true and watch out for postpartum
depression it is a real thing like after
after the book after the book comes out
there's a bit of a climactic moment and
then it's like oh well I guess that
that's that's over what so hopefully
it'll be a couple of it'll be several
weeks on the bestseller list before you
realize that your baby's ugly yeah
exactly so I just asked Glenn this and
I'm where I'm wondering about your
opinion on this so I'm feeling pretty
although the world is crazy and you're
right we're struggling to reopen and you
know we're stuck here in California
where it's gonna be you know really slow
because of our wonderful progressive
politicians but on the idea side I'm
actually feeling pretty hopeful for a
lot of the things that you and I care
about like people suddenly are talking
about states rights I think suddenly
people who weren't that into the Second
Amendment are going oh I should be able
to protect myself and my family people
are going oh I should have the right to
assembly the 4th amendment like a whole
slew of things that I know you and I
care about from an individual liberty
perspective are suddenly they're feeling
kind of cool maybe to a new set of
people are you with me on that or do you
think it sort of polarized I think that
on the one hand whenever you have you
know tens of millions of people out of
work that means that there is going to
be a loud clamor for more government
intervention ISM in the economy and that
scares me a complete rewriting of the
bargain you can see that many Democrats
are right now talking about that
speaking of things like reshaping the
nature of capitalism you saw Bernie
Sanders write a piece like this for the
New York Times basically all of their
priors they don't want to apply in a
time of pandemic because people aren't
worse off than they were a few months
ago it's hard to make the case that you
need to overthrow the American system
with three point five percent
unemployment and wages going up it's a
lot easier to make the case you need
massive government intervention ISM when
you've got fifteen percent unemployment
and millions and millions of people out
of work and people going to food banks
you never thought they'd have to go to a
food bank so that is that frightens me
it's one of the reasons I think that we
need to get back to a free market
opening as soon as possible and also so
that we have more information and so
that we know how the new demand curves
look so people can move out of
industries that are in trouble and into
industries that are going to be growing
you know out of things like retail and
into my online sales for example if this
is going to be a long lasting thing and
there the market will respond to the
situation but we don't know exactly how
yet so on that side I'm kind of
pessimistic on the on the personal
liberty side I'm pretty optimistic I
think people are tired of this the good
news is that the socialist government
will pay for everything came along with
the Socialists we're gonna control every
aspect of your life such that we are
going to scream at you if you walk
outside of your house but I think most
people are not willing to trade the the
security of increasing their life
expectancy by a small amount
particularly if you're young for the for
the risk of the government can keep you
inside all the time forever and it
really does vary by age I mean what I
think the media have been deeply
irresponsible and how they've covered
this I think the politicians have been
deeply irresponsible and how they've
talked about all of this this really
should be an area when we're all on the
same page that but I do I'm in
California with you the weather outside
is beautiful there is a real sense like
we need to get out of this like
immediately when it was raining outside
it was terrible outside like okay well I
guess we you know we're not going
anywhere anyway but now you got the
stupid LA County saying we're gonna shut
down every Park in every beach and so
people in LA or like okay fine I'll just
go to Newport
fine I'll head on over to Burbank or
Pasadena and go to the park and socially
distance cuz I'm a responsible human
being and I'm gonna take care of my kids
and I'm not gonna call on other people
and III think that people eventually are
going to get to the point where they say
I trust the American people enough to
make their own decisions that I don't
need Eric Garcetti or Gavin Newsom
telling me what an essential businesses
do you think some of this is also that
it's just always harder to make a
Liberty based argument just because
people don't really think things through
so it's like right now if you're making
a state-by-state argument which I think
makes sense right Greg Abbott in Texas
he's saying okay we've done this now
we're gonna end it on April 30th and
we'll see what happens but you're gonna
have to like the next step of that is
you're gonna have to acknowledge that it
might cause another spike that's a
little scarier like actually admitting
the truth
rather than just saying no we're just
gonna lock down forever and I think that
almost you know as I've sort of done
what this book is about as I've sort of
evolved politically I've noticed that
it's much much harder to make any
argument from a conservative or
right-leaning perspective because you
actually have to make a real argument as
opposed to just saying something and it
kind of sounds right so then people just
go along with it and that's certainly
true especially when it comes to
calculating risks and rewards in public
policy I think it's really ugly and and
last refuge of the of the political
scandal stuff or Andrew Cuomo for
example to say if we're just gonna save
one life okay well we're just gonna save
one life then you should really like
just confine people to their houses
permanently because the fact is that no
matter how you reopen there will be an
increase in the curve I mean everybody
understands this there will be an
increase in cases but this is because
politicians have basically been fibbing
about this whole thing all along there
was the misimpression that flatten the
curve meant that when we come out the
other side that the curve will be zero
and then of course it's not true
flattening the curve was meant to
prevent the overwhelming of our health
care system we didn't overwhelm our
health care system so now we've done
what we can do the the testing and
tracing thing when people talk about
testing and tracing will make us all
safe no that's not how any of this works
testing and tracing is designed to
locate hot spots and maybe be able to
suppress those hot spots again that they
don't overwhelm the healthcare system
but it's not going to prevent overtime
the area under that curve from being the
same it's just preventing the spikes in
the curve so understanding the sort of
stuff is necessary to understanding
public policy and trying to balance the
risks and rewards here is a difficult
thing the easiest thing you can do is
say all damages caused are caused by the
pandemic
all of the good things that are
happening like you being a
that is caused by me right sort of the
Gretchen Whitmer strategy in Michigan
and ran that's and that's a very easy
thing to say but in reality you know
that not only are there countervailing
issues on the other side such as the
fact that you know people are gonna lose
their jobs and their livelihoods and
their dreams and quality of life
actually matters but none of these
governors are gonna keep things locked
down forever I mean Andrew Cuomo when he
said just save one life five days later
he said we're gonna open up parts of New
York State okay so which is it I mean
obviously that means that more people
are going to be infected so you were
always gonna make this public policy
consideration nobody just wants to say
the obvious truth which is that we're
all making actuarial deductions about
what are the costs in terms of how many
human lives how many how many years of
life because that is an actual issue in
actuarial tables right if somebody who
is 81 dies of copán 19 that is not the
same thing as somebody who is 30 dying
of kovin 19 I mean if this were killing
children every would be interlocked down
forever that's the reality right if a
bunch of five girls were dying of copán
19 and and people are saying get back to
work every billing nope I'm not letting
my five-year-old die if grandpa dies in
a nursing home at age 81 that's tragic
and it's terrible
also the life expectancy in the United
States is 80 so that that is not the
same thing in in moral terms you want to
save every life you can at the same time
to pretend that it is of the same it is
the same calculation the age of the
person no public policy acts like that
not a single public policy in American
life acts like that this is why for
example no driving is a useful economic
activity in many states once you have a
certain age you can't drive anymore and
why because we've made the calculation
that we don't want you crashing to
somebody else and killing them right
there there are lots of things that we
do in public life that are that are
trade-offs politicians have a stake in
pretending they're no trade offs and now
what's what's really crazy is that the
media apparently have a stake in
pretending there are no trade offs I
really blame the media more than the
politicians politicians will never tell
you about the trade offs every policy is
100 percent good or 100 percent bad the
the media pretending that you know Greg
Abbott is terrible but acting like Jared
Paulus the governor of Colorado who's a
Democrat in orange does not exist it's
not even a human being it's crazy
well right we saw we've got whitmer
saying you know you can't go out and buy
seeds and you can't do landscaping in
Michigan well meanwhile people can
actually you know what you do with seeds
Ben and I now know this because I'm
doing it myself
you start
indoors and then you put them outdoors
but also the I just the idea that the
governor would be allowed to say that I
literally mailed seeds to people in
Michigan
just just basically as a fu to her I
mean and it's like you know I'm pretty
sure she's done we should be outdoors
what the hell is she talking about if
the outdoors is the best thing that can
happen to you right now you're far away
from other people there's open air
there's wind the virus doesn't live in
sunlight it doesn't live in heat like
what are you what are you talking about
this is this is why I mean I'm I'm
enraged by Eric Garcetti and Gavin
Newsom I'm just enraged by them I think
this is absurdity to highest level I'm
driving along Mulholland Drive and they
literally deployed somebody put yellow
tape along the overpasses at Mulholland
Drive well you live out here you know
that those overpasses are seven feet
square like what do they think is gonna
happen over there people just gonna get
over there and start making out on
Mulholland Drive and pandemic by the
hundreds and what what in the world but
none of this this is where you get to
the point where you're like okay this is
not actually calibrated to save lives
this is actual posturing beyond a
certain point and and it's convenient
posturing for people who are very fond
of government involvement in our lives
like I don't think that that Eric
Garcetti or Gavin Newsom are a bad will
that they want to destroy Americans
lives and destroy their livelihoods I
just think that for them the
countervailing interests are not as
strong so the countervailing interest
for conservatives are I like freedom I
like I like being able to engage in
economic activity that entrepreneurs
create I like the free market system I
like all of these things and so that is
a countervailing interest to lock down
forever for Democrats like lock down
forever saves lives
and also if that has impacts on the free
market that's actually a net plus right
that's it that's something that we
remake the world in a direction that we
like so it's actually two things in
favor of the lockdown as opposed to
weighing competing values this is why
when people say we're just following the
data or we're just following the science
no the data and science are the same for
everybody we can all look at the data
and the science I would hope right and
be realistic about the risks and they
and particularly two different
populations the real question is what
are your competing values and people who
are not honest that this is really a
question of competing values at this
point are just being dishonest that's
what it is so listen man I know you got
a crazy day and we're gonna do this 20
questions thing that you're gonna rifle
off of me before we get to that though
you hit the media on something and you
and I have been you know sort of bashing
mainstream news for all time now or four
years at least and now it seems like a
lot of people are
getting it like that clip of Chris Cuomo
that stage WWE style clip I mean it's a
it's a skit it's an SNL skit with
writers he comes out of the basement and
he's sweaty because he's been working
out yet he's also chipping his tooth
because of his coronavirus nightmares I
mean the whole thing is nonsense he says
he's been in there for weeks it turns
out that he actually got into a fight
with a bicyclist outside of his house
just a few days before that second a
second ask yeah Rose right second house
but then the media runs cover for him as
if this is all true and then we're
seeing another even more perverse
version of this now which is this Tara
Reid story and putting aside the
allegations about Biden it's like when
this happened to Kavanagh because
Kavanagh is a a conservative we know we
had weeks of literally thousands of
articles about it
the New York Times hid this for weeks
then they put it on page 23 or 24 and
then in the article it's mostly about
Trump or at least a decent portion about
Trump do you think more people right now
are catching on to the media BS than
ever before because we're trapped at
home you're forced to be online so
suddenly you're seeing memes you're
seeing extended clips you're watching a
cost to say one thing and then you can
see the reality a second later so that's
pretty hopeful for us right I mean I do
think that's hopeful I suggested on my
show this morning that the White House
should really end the political
briefings entirely and they should
refuse to allow and will not refuse to
allow but they should they should urge
newspapers to send their health policy
reporters to the White House to talk
with Burks and fowey it's completely
useless I've asked a better question
personally to dr. Burks then the members
of the White House press corps the pret
the White House press corps go there and
they ask questions like Olivia Nuzzi
asking Trump about how many Vietnam War
deaths that works like okay that that is
not a question that it's designed to
elicit an answer it's it's a question
designed to get her on TV Jim Acosta pre
writing his idiotic lines about how lies
don't live in sunlight know this kind of
stuff where he just sits there early
each morning and writes these
overdramatic lines while staring in the
mirror at Jim Acosta and ladies find you
a man who loves you like Jim Acosta
loves Jim Acosta
it really is off-putting the Washington
Post headline by the way that they
tweeted out on the Tara Reid thing for
the first time reporting it was
developments in allegations against
Biden amplify efforts to question his
behavior
not even in English the writing Swahili
headlines at this point who avoids us
saying that there are people who confirm
the terror retold them at the time that
Joe Biden had sexually molested her and
I mean that that's that's what they are
doing yeah I mean people are seeing
through this and the problem is they're
seeing through it at a time when you
actually need the media to be credible
all right you have the media who are
urging people port an action to be
careful with each other and at the same
time half the information they're
reporting is directed at just taking
down Trump and another twenty five
percent of the information is alarmist
nonsense and we're really alarmist
nonsense reporting and and reporting on
polls that is just ridiculous
there's a poll I saw today where
somebody who the poll was what
percentage of people think that we
shouldn't that we should lock down until
the virus is contained and it's like
that is the vaguest poll question I have
ever seen I mean the virus is contained
how are you talking about there are
800,000 active cases in the United
States that we know about which means
that in reality you're looking more at
like five million active cases in the
United States probably four or five
million cases in the United States so
like it's all based on on nonsense it's
all based on on silliness you know
trying to bring people straight
information is becoming more and more
difficult I think people recognize that
it's why people are turning online it's
why people are turning to YouTube and
then you'll see YouTube YouTube said the
other day that they're gonna take down
any video that doesn't comply with sort
of w-h-o standards and it's like well if
you'd help that standard back in January
and I had said in mid-january that there
was human to human transmission you
would have taken that down if I had said
at the beginning of March by the way I
did say this at the beginning of March
once the stats started to come out that
the actual death rate from this thing
was not three or four percent who's
actually below 1 percent then presumably
under those standards that could be
taken down the kind of appeal to
Authority by YouTube's you shut down
particular data even instead of just
allowing me free argument is again
another area where people are starting
to lose faith in our institutional
gatekeepers they've forced to the choice
between there are no gatekeepers and
these people are the gatekeepers more
and more people are opting for there
ought to be no gatekeepers which by the
way I don't think it's the right
solution I think the right so yes I
agree
better gatekeepers right but but there
but that doesn't mean but if I'm forced
to the choice I'll say no gatekeepers
and and you know I think that more
conference it the conversation is not
about gatekeeping it's about the actual
debate and winning the debate
that's such a great point because I'm
with you on that I I don't believe we
can have a no gatekeeping absolute
free-for-all like just in for me we
could have in I want as much information
out there as possible an exchange of
information and free thought and all
that but the idea that there'd be no
gatekeeping it would it would be like
everyone will just believe whatever they
want to believe and will be totally
screwed but it's like well I think we
should be clear here so people don't
take you out of context I'm not saying
that people should be the platform what
I'm saying is that what some of the
people who argue no gatekeeping mean is
that you Dave Rubin should be forced to
have conversations with any conspiracy
whereas they could name and then write
you you're not under that obligation at
the same time I think the platform's
generally you know should be have as
wide latitude as possible for free
speech and allow particularly
information that they may not disagree
with so they're I think we're in
agreement okay I need to ask you by the
way we should add we should add that if
we were doing this by whao guidelines
and YouTube was taken down videos they
were also telling us not to wear masks
what was that about six weeks ago so if
you were telling people to wear masks
six weeks ago you would have been taken
down at that point so it's all bananas
it's crazy
okay so let's ask you some of these
rights appear on 22 it Dave Rubin
Llosa's who is your all-time favorite
guest - on the Rubin report and I'm
gonna add a caveat you're not allowed to
say Jordan Peterson I can't say Jordan
Peterson I'm gonna say Richard Lewis the
comedian Richard Lewis I always loved
him and just to sit across from him and
think that he's in curb I just love it
okay what's also a relocate - because
because you're going to relocate right I
mean there's no chance you stay here
long-term I mean I mean Texas I got so
many people begging me to come to Texas
I feel like I could be governor there
and about half a minute if you could
meet any president who would it be
well if it doesn't matter if they're
living or dead I mean I think I would do
George Washington but if they're living
I mean I would like to talk to Trump I
believe it or not I know you we've
discussed this there would be a extreme
cost at talking to him publicly I have
talked to him privately but I'd like to
do it
okay best book that you've read this
year aside from your own huh you know I
really loved bright side of history I'm
not just saying that because you're on I
actually I actually referenced it a
couple times in the book and I think it
gives a good explanation of why we there
are there is a history of learning that
that we should know and acknowledge
points for kisi a story for dave rubin
right there what is your husband David's
favorite food to cook
well I know tonight because it is my
book launch night I'm having him make my
favorite thing which is cast-iron
chicken parm wedding cake right I mean
wedding cake is the obvious answer there
correct I mean come on
and you're the only one I would let make
me a wedding cake come on now I know I'm
the only one who'd bring you a cupcake
instead who do you want to get on the
Reuben report this year
I really want Bill Maher because I think
he's basically the last sane liberal and
I'm doing the show on May 29th and I
want to get into some of this stuff but
you you've done it it's like I'll have
five minutes with him but I want an hour
with this guy to really discuss what I
think are maybe his blind spots related
to the left will you ever run for office
Oh God you know I've told people if
Shapiro ever runs for president I'll be
press secretary I could see maybe maybe
when I'm retired I'm talking 65 70 I
could see maybe being a mayor in a tiny
small town but that's that's probably it
but I like about secretary idea
something like that
apparently 65 is like the new is it like
the new 40 because you have to be at
least 90 years old to run for president
at this point that's that's actually
when you're when you're dead you'll run
for president if you were president what
would be your first initiative
oh man I'd cut the federal budget in
half just like that and guess what we'd
be okay
goto alcoholic debate drink
alcohol if I'm debating somebody if I'm
debating somebody and I really want to
get into it like we're really gonna go
at it tequila I mean you give me some
tequila I'm alive I'm awake I'm ready to
roll I know you're a margarita man
yourself absolutely real manliness is in
the rum rita
margaret with rum the worst drink of
magic with your little I've seen your
little umbrella yeah I'm not gonna go
with this bullcrap
oh masculinity we're gonna have whiskey
and on pipe nonsense I have three
children I don't need your full
masculinity Shabbat dinner this weekend
with me or dennis prager
that's messed up Shabbat well you know
I've done it with Prager so we're due
for one of these when we can actually do
it in real life we're do yeah that's
good I'll get best part and worst part
of living in LA
the best part is what's happened over
the last couple years that there's
something sane brewing here that you and
Prager and Peter teal there's like this
new interesting not woke thing happening
here and it's actually kind of cool the
worst part of living in LA is is well
the traffic's the easy one the worst
part is that that we really are outliers
in our own community and but I will say
the silver lining to that is when I'm
walking the dog down the street these
days a lot of people come up to me and
they'll kind of hint they'll be like
Dave I'm like you you know so it's
coming around
favorite show host at the daily wire
ah then I've given you way too much
credit so far you know I think Clavin is
just such a freaking clear thinker I
mean all you guys are great but I Clavin
there's something about him that's a
little bit like you know he's like
you're wise uncle that I just find his
his thinking is clear he's at an
interesting personal evolution hey it's
a good guy hey chick-fil-a or in and out
and remember I have no frame of
reference for this question oh right
you've never had either one of them you
poor soul um chip well look I'm an LA
guy we have mostly in and out here and I
actually do miss in and out but I do
enjoy that chicken sandwich
all righty best place you have traveled
to well on tour since you're never
traveling again so now now your summer
vacation is booked for your kitchen well
what's the best place that you've
traveled without on tour while on tour
the best place I mean truly the
stockholm sweden shows that i did with
Jordan were so absolutely extraordinary
because the people there are so starved
for free speech and something decent and
it's like Bernie and aoc constantly tell
you how amazing Sweden is and yet if you
go there you see people that are just
afraid of their own shadow and going
there and embracing those people is
incredible and it's also this is all
over Sweden's gonna be the only country
left standing of hair they're not gonna
get swamped by a second wave what is
your favorite Praeger you video
Ben I got to tell you man I don't know
if you saw it but my new one my third
one that went up yesterday it's called
the bravery deficit your I mentioned you
in there I I think it's one of the best
things I've ever done actually I know
that's very self-effacing to talk about
myself but it's pretty damn good
coolest artifact in Glenn Beck studio
collection other than the actual skull
of your ex from Hamlet he has so many
unbelievable bit well he has he has one
of three I believe there were three of
them in existence the original three
Darth Vader helmets that were from the
1977 New Hope Star Wars and I actually
got to put it on for a photo shoot I did
over there Glenn wasn't there and his
assistant was like oh yeah
you can put it on and I was like if I
break this thing it's over but freaking
heavy and it and it smells in there and
but yeah Darth Vader helped me a lot is
that the one that he takes off like
right at the end where he's got the ugly
face underneath that was that do you
know which which Darth Vader helmet it
was well I think I think it was from the
77 new hope now originally the Jedi yeah
I think so yeah Wow okay yeah I feel
like I might die richer than Glenn
because Glenn has so much stuff you
spent so much money
yes yes Dorothy's ruby red slippers I
mean the guy is not messing around that
is that is amazing
what is the most important rule from 12
rules for life
oh stand up straight with your shoulders
back it's the easiest one of course in
terms of just it's like the cliche one
but I think presenting something strong
and powerful to the world actually
starts making you behave ballet what is
your favorite Star Wars Episode and what
you know we'll just put aside Empire
because obviously the answer is Empire
you know what I'm gonna I'll say
something controversial for the purposes
of this Revenge of the Sith well we've
discussed it Revenge of the Sith is an
excellent movie they did everything they
had to do in that movie and if US if
Hayden Christensen it may be taking a
couple acting classes that would have
been nice but it is a it is a from the
beat one to the end it is an excellent
movie once our once once of order 66
comes out then things start to get real
and that's that that the rest of that
movie is actually quite good I my theory
by the way I'm kind of on board with
Count Dooku I'll be honest with you I've
never understood why count two who is
the villain Count Dooku is actually like
the only person who is speaking sanity
throughout he tries to recruit Ewan
McGregor at one point he's like by the
way you know it turns out you're working
for a bad guys like no you lie like
Count Dooku man count Utica for
president then they needed to give Dooku
about 10 more minutes to explain all
that cuz you're right he was he was
telling obi-wan the truth in that moment
and clones when he's when he's hung up
there he's saying dude the Senate under
control by the bad guy join me join me
and yeah didn't work out it just shows
cuz I mean if they listened to him in
trade liberalisation know it that would
have changed everything what breed is
your dog Clyde
we don't know exactly Clyde's right over
here he's chewing the the step he's part
pit probably part Terrier maybe a little
Basenji in there something something
something would you make me a wedding
cake
nah-uh well I'd literally never baked so
I would do it just out of sheer you know
curiosity and you know something feeling
of moral superiority naturally so Dave
it's been good to talk to you I got to
get back to my show but you're gonna
sell a bajillion of these books folks go
out and buy don't burn this book by Dave
Rubin also for the ancillary mentions of
great Americans like me go check out
don't burn this book it's worth the read
all right thanks brother I know you got
a busy day I appreciate it you back
catching it all right be good
alright that was Ben Shapiro ladies and
gentlemen and now I'm gonna continue
signing books and taking your questions
I talked to Glenn Beck I've talked to
Ben Shapiro I am signing don't burn this
book this is a new Sharpie by the way
there's nothing like a new sharpie on
fresh paper it is is the scent I'm
getting high over here the the sort of
liquid movement across the page I
actually do love it alright so if you
want to get a signed copy of don't burn
this book you can get one go to premiere
collectibles dot-com slash Rubin and you
can ask me a question right now so I'm
going to get to more your questions and
I'm sign-in books
Michael message for you can you just
delete some of the ones that I've read
already that'll make it a little easier
for me oh I was answering a question by
Lauren about civil liberties that people
are giving them up and do I see this
trend continuing well what I am worried
about Lauren is that the more we go on
with this thing right so here in LA for
example and most of California we're
almost at two months now of this we're
almost at two freaking months of being
trapped in our houses what I'm worried
about is the old world remember where we
used to go bowling and you might go out
for dinner and meet a friend for a beer
and go to Starbucks and do some other
stuff take a walk what I'm worried about
is the more that we do this will
actually start to forget what the old
world was like and I'm also worried
about the fact that right now it seems
like it all these small businesses these
mom-and-pop shops they're gonna all be
taken away and that is the backbone of
American society and we're only gonna
have change stores that can survive
things like this and all that so I'm
worried that we will sort of give up our
civil liberties just by by just
following the rules all the time so
that's why I've said this before a
couple of times it's like
if if right now we have to decide when
to open up and how to do it I'm going to
be one of the people that is going to be
pushing harder on do it sooner and do it
faster not not with reckless abandon but
I am very worried that we are going to
just forget the old world we're gonna
sort of accept this new normal will all
be under the thumb of big tech even more
because this will be how well the only
way we're gonna be able to communicate
and I think it's deeply dangerous you
know as a guy that interviews people for
a living
I miss sitting across from people you
know like I miss it I had a friend in
New York City who's single and he I
spoke to him a couple days ago I said
this on a live stream recently and he
said he said Dave you know more than
anything else I miss human touch you
know he hasn't touched anybody in two
months that's not good like I want to
hug my mom you know it's like we got to
get back to some of this stuff and I am
worried that we'll forget what what made
us as a country so special which is that
we fight for our civil liberties like
nobody else on earth alright I'm signing
books people get your signed copy but
don't burn this book at premier
collectibles dot-com slash Rubin and all
right let's jump over siku in venire
ontario says are there any modern
feminists that you would consider having
on the reuben report yes absolutely you
know it's unfortunate I guess when you
say modern feminists you mean sort of
third wave intersectional feminist not
christina hoff sommers style feminists
so obviously I'm more in line with say
the first wave feminists Camille Paglia
christina hoff sommers that that
generation of feminists which wanted
equality of opportunity not equality of
outcome and but I'd be happy as long as
someone will treat me with respect I
mean I say this all the time you're a
decent person you're gonna treat me with
respect and have an honest conversation
I'm gonna have that conversation with
you all right I'm signing books people
we are signing books by the way if you
haven't picked up your copy and you can
get it on Amazon or I guess we're
pushing premier collectibles comics legs
Rubin right now some of the people that
you might see on the back of the book
that gave me some really great blurbs
Jordan Peterson you might have heard of
that guy this Ben Shapiro character
Eckhart Tolle not bad not bad the power
and now
Peter teal Tucker Carlson and my friend
Larry King all gave blurbs for the book
which is great and I am signing these
copies right now by the way a whole
bunch of you I'm not gonna say it right
now because I don't want to give it away
but a whole bunch I feel that's a very
good signature right there
that was like a real good one right
there a whole bunch of you have already
sent me funny comments about who I book
dedicated the book to so if you haven't
seen it yet you should see it I think
many of you will understand why I
dedicated it to this person and I will I
do explain further in the book why I did
that okay let's see Paul in Toninho
Washington says do you feel like the
left has abandoned people who are simply
gay or lesbian to be more woke for all
other genders yeah I mean that we know
this right like if you're if you're a
gay well especially if you're a gay
white man you're now considered
privileged by the left's endless need to
take everybody down a peg as it is sort
of a sense it's climbed to power so if
you're just a white you know the in
their pecking order if you're a Latina
lesbian you're above a gay white man and
if you're a black genderqueer
something-or-other you're above that
person I mean these things it's all a
series a picture it of as as either a
house of cards or if you were to build
like something out of toothpicks it's
like none of this makes sense and
everyone knows it doesn't make sense but
people keep playing along but I am I am
sort of concerned about that because you
know it all started actually the first
moment where I realized the left was
done with the gays in effect was it was
actually the day I met Peter teal this
is now about four or five years ago and
that very day there was the article I
think it was an advocate magazine maybe
it was an out magazine but no but nobody
reads these gay magazines anymore which
it's fine I mean they're they're not
relevant anymore because gay people are
equal and Zippity damn do and nobody
wants special right well I don't want
special right but there was an article
about how Peter teal he's not gay
and what they meant by that it's not
that he has he's my happens he's married
to a man but that's not gay in their me
in their view what gay is is that you
have to identify with all their
politics so they've actually the left is
actually started and the far left
radicals have started to take away
sexuality from gay people so it really
it's just it's a hysterical monster that
we need to put to bed and by the way I
think we are putting it to bed and I
think I hope that this book will do a
yeoman's job of making that happen
Tana asks in ponce inlet ponce a inlet
florida who's been your favorite person
to interview on the rubin report sir
shapiro asked me this he said I can't
say Peterson I said Richard Lewis the
comedian I just I just love that you
know it's kind of funny as an interview
I don't think it was one of my best
because he's a comic and you know a lot
of these guys you just have to sit them
down you wind them up and they go so I
didn't have to do much during the
interview but I just loved talking to
this guy who I've always loved who I
think is one of the one of the great
comics that we have but I'll give you
another one let me see I'll give you
another one who else have I loved well I
think Douglas Mari
I mean Douglas Murray is like is
basically like the clearest cleanest
thinker that we've got I don't I can't
even think of anything off the top of my
head that I have like a severe political
disagreement with him on not that that
would matter actually but he's just a
great thinker and he's fun and he's
funny and he's he's just interesting and
he's wonderful
let's see Matthew in Cranbourne West
Victoria says do you think the
coronavirus will draw us more into local
trade and a step away from globalism I
hope so but if you just listen to a band
was saying it's like a lot of the the
socialist types so what you're sort of
calling the globalists here they're
gonna use this as an excuse for major
government takeovers over everything and
major government handouts and that's
going to be appealing to a certain
amount of people but I think those of us
that are Liberty minded and if you
believe in competition and capitalism
and you believe in human ingenuity and
if you believe in more than anything
else if you believe in humanity meaning
that it go find what you want to do in
this world it's like we better start
helping out small businesses help out
your local restaurants and all of those
things because nobody wants to work for
giant chains it's like working for the
government that's like a soul-sucking
thing it doesn't mean that people who
work for the government or bad people
but like we all want like what would you
rather do as a let's say you want to be
in the food service business would you
wrap people I get into food service like
the idea is I'm gonna own my own
restaurant one day because it's yours
you get to do with it what you want you
get pride and passion and then you can
learn and build a business like I've
built here and that's a beautiful thing
oh that's a great signature right there
there you go
so I I hope that people will remember
that and I really hope that people will
will continue to support small
businesses and I'll do my share when
this starts opening up and when we've
been buying things on Amazon right now
we've been trying to do you know some of
their some of their partners and not
just go to the big boys the entire time
let's see Brent enabling Texas what
books are podcasts would you recommend a
leftist to watch I mean I can't possibly
recommend anything more than if you've
got a friend who's a lefty or like kind
of on the fence or just trying to figure
the freakin thing out that's what this
is this is a road map so that they can
think for themselves I don't I don't
belittle people in this I talk about the
ideas I talk about what I think the
right ideas are and what I think the
wrong ideas are and I give you a sort of
road map for you yourself right so I'm
guessing if you ask me this question
Brent you've probably got a a lefty
sibling or friend or brother or whatever
it may be and you want to give them
something that will help wake them up I
think this is done right there's just
enough humor in it I don't take myself
too seriously but I talk about ideas and
in a in a dense interesting way and I
think it's the right I think it's the
right path to get some of them on let's
see Karen in Port Orchard Washington
says why aren't we pushing back against
the educational system that is teaching
our children what to think instead of
how to think well I think a lot of us
are pushing back by the way this is
completely why and I talked about this
in the book that I'm completely for
school choice and I'm completely for
charter schools you know it's so funny
this is one of those things that on the
Left they're constantly telling you how
bad our education system is and
everything's not funded well in blah
blah blah and then they don't want
school choice they don't want parents to
be able to pick which schools their
children are able to go to they don't
want charter schools they
want everything done by the state
authoritarian power telling everyone
what to do but to the heart of your
question should I move some of these
down maybe probably yeah I was gonna
create a Tower of Babel here now we're
gonna shift them over a little bit here
why don't I do this then people can
maybe see some of the copies of the book
they're you know so I think what we need
here is as much choice as possible I
actually think homeschooling is probably
gonna come back way stronger right now
because I think a lot of people are
enjoying it they're realizing they've
been putting a ton of money into private
schools and it's not like every private
school is perfect too so I think there
we're in a massive moment of change
right now and what I keep telling you
guys is the people that view everything
through the permanent partisan political
lens left this right this that's not
really the way to look at it do you want
to be free or do you believe that
someone else has a has better
understanding of how you should live
your life and I think more and more
people are gonna realize that and you
can even see the the system the
gatekeeper fighting against it it was
the Harvard Review I believe it was that
put out this really awful article but
the the cartoon on the front the
implication was that home schooling is
dangerous because the you know the kids
are only gonna learn about the Bible and
some core subjects and not like all this
other stuff and it's like I don't know
it's up to the parent it's up to the
parent huh let's see
Alex in Austin Texas how do we solve the
media problem in the United States
without infringing on free speech or
looking like we have state-controlled
narrative oh we got a huge problem with
the media and I just talked to Ben about
this
I mean we're watching them sort of
collapse right cNN has basically become
a fiction CNN is a it's not even a
fiction it's it's just made-up nonsense
and and they expose themselves every day
I mean these these quote-unquote
journalists are activists I am NOT a
journalist I have never wanted to be a
journalist I did a video yesterday
talking about how the media is covering
for Biden with these Tara Reid
allegations I didn't want to do it even
in the morning as I was discussing it
with my team I was like I'm not a
newsman this isn't what I want to cover
but it's like in a weird way any if you
care about truth at any level we've been
left having to cover for the media which
has just totally dropped the ball so I
do I look I don't think the state should
be funding and I don't think the state
should be funding NPR or anything the
state shouldn't be funding media at any
level I'm sorry if some people are gonna
lose their jobs and some things are
gonna lose funding but hopefully if
they're good at what they do they'll
figure out other ways to do it
Hey look at me right like there's a
there's a way to do it you guys support
what we do by the way our live stream
yesterday because I talked about pride
in and Tara Reid of course it was
demonetised so we make no money on that
but you guys support us however many of
you do support us at Rubin report calm
and you can pay whatever you want you
get ad free video and podcast and all
that and that allows me to make the
right choices based on what I think it's
important to talk about rather than
what's just gonna make us money but what
are we gonna do
ah we have a huge problem and I think
more than anything else I mean this is
why I started locals you you should just
support the people that you think are
doing something basically close to the
truth that you think are trying to put
something good out there because the
mainstream media is not coming back
the social justice monster the the
progressive monster these things have
infected these systems the New York
Times is infected CNN is infected these
things will not come back but new things
will come and one of the things I've
been thinking about lately is you know
so many of us and I include myself in
this we spend so much time railing
against CNN and the rest of it and it's
like maybe we should just let them die
the slow death like maybe we need to
stop talking about them because nobody's
watching them and the whole economic
model doesn't even make sense what I
what it cost me to do a year of my show
is probably one night of Anderson Cooper
and very few people are watching that
anyway so all of this is up in the air
and just just try to support whether
that means watching or donating or
whatever the people that you think are
decent Alex in Lenexa Kansas do you
think you will ever do a video series
unrelated to politics you know I really
would love to and I don't know if you've
noticed but I've been trying a little
bit to talk about politics a little bit
less lately you know I'm more interested
in the culture thing and as a lot of
people talk about politics is sort of
downstream from culture but now that
culture is sort of catching up to kind
of where we've been at if you've been
watching the show for a couple years
like politics is sort of melded into
culture now it's all sort of one thing
that's wrapped in a Trumpy and bow or
something like that and I'm not that
interested in politics this is the irony
for for people that are somewhat
libertarian minded you know it's very
easy for a socialist or a progressive to
be like angry all the time and screaming
about politics all the time because they
believe politics is everything they
believe in their perfect society they
believe that we can build something that
will solve all of humanity's problems if
you're more Liberty minded it's like I
don't believe that that thing can be
built I certainly don't think that I can
do it what I can talk about is things
that I care about that hopefully will
allow people to live a better life for
themselves right that's what I think is
better but but that's less quickly right
like that's less you know look at me
look what I'm doing and I think that
that is sort of a problem so we have one
side that's like sort of hysterical in
nature because they think that their
salvation comes from all of the things
that they believe in and another side
that just wants to be left alone because
you might be more interested in art or
in politics or in basketball or video
games your knitting and that sort of
asymmetry I think makes it tough for the
limit Liberty minded people to win an
argument also you know progressives are
really good about screaming a slogan $15
minimum wage free college for everybody
it's just a slogan none of it makes any
economic sense or even sort of basic
political sense while people on the
right you know they'll talk about ideas
all day long so that I've done this a
million times I go to libertarian
conferences and I get a drink at the bar
after and suddenly I got surrounded by
20 people and we're debating whether
driver's licenses should exist it's an
interesting fun debate and I love having
it but it not it isn't necessarily the
best way to sell the product of Liberty
so I think I got there Mary in Lake
Tapps Washington says no question just a
big thank you for being fair and
balanced thank you Mary
Rob in Williamsburg Virginia says love
your story and looking forward to
reading the book do you think that
you'll ever have president Trump on your
show so if you didn't see it we put up a
video last week where my husband David
and I we talked about meeting Trump at
mar-a-lago in December and you can buy
it you should watch the video I won't
tell you the whole story here but I
assure you first off that he has no
problem with gay people fart it's far
more than that actually and you should
watch the video to see what he said to
us and all that I had an interesting
conversation interesting conversation I
would love to have him on I'm gonna I'm
gonna sort of nudge jr. a little bit to
see if I could get him and I think by
the way I think for Trump
I think it would be a really wise move
to do a show like this ah not a show
like this I think it would be a wise
move to do this show for Trump because I
would treat him the exact same way I've
treated every single one of my guests
whether they're whether I agreed with
them or not I would treat him fairly I
wouldn't be trying to get him I would
actually just want to hear what he says
about these things I know it would
unleash a world of hate on me but I
guess this is the life that I chose so
here we are been in San Francisco
California good luck up there Ben you're
gonna need it says since your
conversation with Larry elder what other
profound shifts in your worldview have
you experienced well I would say that
the one thing that I've really shifted
and more than anything else because
because many of my views are the same
actually but I view them now more
through what I would say is the
classical liberal or libertarian
perspective meaning individual liberty
it's your life do it you want
perspective as opposed to the state has
to force people to do certain things I
would say I've shifted economically for
sure and that that is not only from
talking to a lot of libertarian
economists the most notably Thomas Sol
and reading several of Sol's books one
of them discrimination disparities right
over there it's that in the process of
building this show and doing everything
that I've been doing I've started a
small business I actually have not only
the production company that runs the
Rubin report but I started locals calm
so I started a tech business too and I
put all of my principles in play in the
businesses that I have right so like the
most simple way of explaining it is the
lower my taxes are in this absurdly
obscenely high taxed place of Los
Angeles when you lower my taxes I can
hire more people we hired a new
associate producer in the middle of
coronavirus right
we gave our guys bonuses because they're
busting their butts the government
didn't force us to do anything but I
know if my taxes go down we have some
more money it doesn't mean I'm gonna go
buy a boat or buy a bajillion dollar
house what it means is I can do more for
my business so literally right now I
give you my word government authorities
if you're listening please do this if
you lower my taxes again in a
considerable way and I know you need all
that money to do god knows what you do
at California but if you lower my taxes
I will hire more people
I mean that my conversation with David
all the time is that we would love to
hire more people because we have a we
have our guys are especially now in a
time of corona working harder than ever
before the more you raise my taxes the
less I can give to my employees so I
think once I made that shift and you
realize oh you want people to have more
of what they earn it's like what what is
the government doing that is so
spectacular that we should just be
giving them more money how about we give
more right now you didn't see lefties
seeing this I saw a prominent blue check
lefty who's like a far far progressive I
saw him saying something about how we
should be suspending taxes for the next
three months and it's like I don't know
that I totally agree with that but it's
like oh well lefties are waking up and
going oh people need their own money in
times of crisis so I don't want to be in
a time of crisis all the time but how
about we just give people back some more
of their money and and stop letting the
government just take and take and take
and take
Zachery and st. James New York says what
do you believe is Trump's biggest hurdle
coming into 2020
I mean without question it's gonna be
Corona and the economy right so if the
economy is really tanking if just we
cannot get out of this if the states are
all sputtering to reopen well then Biden
just has to stand there and if he can
get one thought out cohesively he just
has to say hey I'm not Trump why not
give it a shot the economy's shot right
so why not give it a shot the economy
shot that could that could be his slogan
so I think that Trump's biggest hurdle
is that it'll it'll be sort of what man
reference which is that the media and
most of the elites they don't want the
economy to open in a certain way and
it's not just because they really care
about you it's because they really
really want to stick it to Trump I think
that's just an uncomfortable depressing
truth so we have to figure out a way to
break through some of the media
narrative and that isn't to say everyone
should open up tomorrow and do whatever
they want we should pack stadiums filled
with people but we do need to get back
to life it is time we did what we were
supposed to do the numbers are way lower
than everyone predicted now partly maybe
we over blew it partly that that's great
social distancing and we when we did
flatten the curve but the media went so
in on and I still see this from even
former guests on the show who have
massive trump derangement syndrome
saying crazy things about Trump has
blood on his hands at 40,000 Americans
Livan it's like actually the numbers are
way less across the board across the
board so anyway I think you see my point
that we we've got to reopen and I think
if we reopen and people I believe the
Roaring Twenties could be coming I
really do I think people are gonna be
excited to communicate again and go out
again and be out and about and support
small businesses I hope that you know as
we're gonna watch tons of picture your
your strip mall in your town like most
of those stores are closed right now and
they're gonna probably remain closed and
a lot of people are gonna get out of
business but my hope is that new people
will get into business and it'll be on
us to to help the people that we can
help Andrew in Columbus Indiana bourbon
or Scotch you know I've had a couple
good Bourbons lately during the during
the quarantine here I've had some good
bourbon I've got some over there I don't
know what it is off the top of my head
so I'd say more of a bourbon guy I know
that's probably very controversial and I
will pay for that in the comment section
oh this is a great question by Connor
sign of books by the way guys what am I
doing here
go to premier collectibles calm slash
Ruben I am signing copies of jumper in
this book which finally came out today
and I'm doing crazy press all day long
oh right after we end this livestream
which is soon right we got maybe about
10 minutes left I have a tiny little
break I think I'm gonna pee and then
I'll be on Dana Perino this afternoon
and then I will be on Tucker Carlson
this evening and strangely I did I
didn't get invited by I didn't get
invited by Cuomo or Maddow
I don't know Here I am guys if you want
to chat happy to do it Michael in
Middleton Idaho what are your current
feelings about and future predictions on
the state of the UN and the EU the UN I
mean I think how crazy this is we're in
the midst of this worldwide pandemic
when's the last time the UN did anything
the UN has completely collapsed I think
Trump pushed the collapse which is
probably good the UN was a deeply deeply
especially the Security Council just a
deeply awful corrupt organization that
every day they would spend all day long
trying to figure out how to sanction
Israel which is an obscenely tiny
country the size of New Jersey in the
worst neighborhood instead of doing
anything functional the UN has done
nothing related to the pandemic as far
as I know
so I sense that the UN is probably
collapsing which is fine let's have
independent nations decide what
alliances they want to be in best and if
you want more of my thoughts on that I
mean I reference it in the book you
should read the virtue of nationalism
which I have right there by your um
[ __ ] Oni which is a which is an
excellent book on why strong independent
nations are the future not not globalism
if you care about freedom and people
being able to make choice of living
where they want to live and the EU I
mean I mean I sense that the EU is
probably gonna crumble it's probably in
the crumbling process already right
brags it happened and I think people are
gonna realize after this that you want
your government to be able to control
your borders and you don't need people
in Brussels to tell you how to live if
you live in Manchester
okay carmine in Ajax Ontario no
questions just wanted to let you know I
respect your views and efforts to help
improve this world of ours thank you
very much Lisa in Deer Park Texas who
painted the artwork behind you in your
videos just curious as I think it is
beautiful you're great too so this is an
original by Kalin Janet her website is
Kailen
Rose Janet calm CA y li n Rose Janet
calm she did all of our originals so she
did this one she did the one that sits
behind the guest over there and many of
you have seen some of the artwork in my
house she did that incredible 5 foot by
8 foot front of the Millennium Falcon
going into hyperspace and there's prints
you can get prints of this by the way
over there I don't get a dime she did
him this is the original she put she
knows how much I love coffee so some of
the texture and there is actually coffee
grinds that I used I think a little bit
of Emma's hair is in there Emma our dog
who has since passed that's Clyde is
rolling around over here
she's a wickedly amazing artist who does
huge huge prints I'll take some pictures
of more of the stuff that she's done but
Kaelyn Rose Janet calm Ulysses in Carson
California I'm planning on writing my
first book any advice considering my
book came out today I don't know that I
can give you any great advice other than
write what you believe write what you
believe that's it man I mean just don't
you know there are things in this book
that are gonna piss off everybody like I
trust I promise you look I you know I'm
gonna piss off some lefties with this
but but the Conservatives are not going
to be thrilled with some of this stuff
to the section on abortion the last line
of the chapter now that you all hate me
let's move on but I wrote what is true
and and I will stand with that and I
think that that's really the best thing
that you could do it's almost the only
thing that you could do bobbi and
Frederick Maryland would it be possible
for a third party to replace the
Democrats today like the Republicans did
with the Whigs
the really interesting topic and I
really should do a history show on what
happened with the Republicans and the
Whigs but I think something interesting
is gonna happen look a OC and Joe Biden
should not be in the same party Joe
Biden should be somewhere else all
together right now
but that they need to split the
socialist let Bernie and the Socialists
have their party and let the old-school
Democrats or whatever that thing is I
don't even know what it is anymore let
them have that and then let have more of
the Liberty minded people sort of beyond
the right and the fact that
conservatives and libertarians can be in
the same party and fight it out that you
know sorry Rand Paul and Trump can be in
the same party and be allies despite you
know Trump is definitely more of a big
government guy than Rand Paul but they
can fight it out
because they have a basic ideology
that's the same the left has no cohesive
ideology anymore other than they all
they all kind of dig government and that
that is a problem so I would love to see
them split they should split there
because they're just faking it now and
it doesn't make sense
let's see Joel in Portugal asks what
books do you recommend reading for a
better understanding of our current
thought landscape I mean I I'm not just
saying this because Shapiro joined me
but his last book the right side of
history I just think is an excellent
example he talks about how so much of
our ideas came from Jerusalem and came
from Athens so sort of like a biblical
understanding of the world and then our
logical understanding of the world in
Athens Greece and I just think it's a
wonderful book and also Glenn's last
book which is totally fun and I
interviewed him it's going up this week
it's called arguing with socialists and
it's not like a traditional you know
book like this it's it's filled with
cartoons and funny memes and all sorts
of stuff and it's like it's just like a
nice easy way to get a lot of
information in a kind of fun way and
okay just a couple more I'm sorry guys I
didn't know let me do a couple shoutouts
Garry turned 28 today happy birthday
Bryan turned 30 today happy birthday
let's see oh and if you are getting your
book today and you got one and it's
signed er it's not signed tag at Rubin
report on instagram with hashtag dumper
in this book and we'll reshare things on
my story oh oh and we're doing a book
club for the for the book don't burn
this book so there are ten chapters in
the book and I'm gonna have ten
different guests do a 20-minute
interview with me discussing the main
core of each chapter we've taped the
first couple of them so I believe it is
next Monday the first one will go up and
Douglas Murray talks to me about chapter
one of the book and then we're gonna do
put two a week up for five weeks and
love to get your thoughts on it and then
we'll be in the Rubin report community
discussing it so that's where I'm trying
to move all of my real discussion with
people because that's where real people
are and there's no trolls and BOTS and
endless haters and the rest of it I'm
sorry to say that's just what a lot of
the rest of the internet has become so
you can go to Rubin report comm and sign
up there and we've got a Apple iOS app
and an Android app and the rest of it
and we'll be
we'll be discussing it we've just got
tons of great people in there and when a
troll does come in guess what I boot
them and that's not an infringement on
their free speech because they can be in
anyone elses local but my local Reuben
report com is my digital home and I'm
for free speech but I don't invite
everybody into my house to tell me I'm
an [ __ ]
that's my policy and I'm sure you have
yours okay so what else all right let me
could try to get to a couple more real
quick I know we're in a Russian I got to
get to I gotta get to Dana Perino Oh
real quick the the premium collectables
dot-com slash Reuben link will remain up
after this so that's where all I'm not
gonna be signing copies after this
except at live events but god only knows
when we're gonna be doing live event so
that's where you will be able to get
live sorry signed copies of don't burn
this book and I'll do three more real
quick what do you read in Forest Hills
Queens he says what do you think your
SUNY Binghamton political science
teachers think of you now I have no idea
but I will tell you this I left there as
a lefty so out if something went wrong
but I did have one great professor in my
senior year who really was pushing
free-thinking who I really loved and I
don't remember his name oh it's gonna
drive me crazy
I don't know but I was invited I was
gonna speak at Binghamton and then I got
canceled because of this so we'll make
it happen
[Music]
Brandon in Staten Island would you agree
that a balanced society would have
conservative and classical liberal
values yes absolutely that's what a
functioning society should have we
should have a push and pull between more
traditional values and more liberal
values and that is what makes a modern
society that doesn't want to burn
everything down but wants to honor
tradition and know that our grandparents
also tried to build something good and
it doesn't erase history you want a push
between modernity and the past
that's what liberalism and conservatives
conservatism should be fighting for and
I wish I could do this all day guys but
I have such a crazy day of interviews by
the way if you haven't seen it yet GAD
sad put an interview with me on his
channel
Michael malice just put one on his
channel and you I love God I love malice
malice really pushed me on a bunch of
stuff which was totally fun Michael
Shermer just put up an interview with me
um
okay oh the pen the pen is running dry
it is a sign so I'm gonna stop right
there I'll do this last one because I
have to get to this because I haven't
talked about anything sci-fi this whole
time Rebecca in Warner Robins Georgia
asks me do you think that the sci-fi
fantasy genre has value beyond simple
entertainment absolutely specifically do
you think that they are able of
conveying truths about humanity that
other genres can't yes and that's why I
love science fiction and every night
that we're trying to watch a movie we
always go to science fiction first if
you want to watch an interesting movie I
think it's on Netflix it's a I believe
it's Swedish it's called Ani aria and
it's about a ship that gets lost in
space and basically breaks down and the
people don't know that they're never
gonna get off the ship until awhile and
then it takes place over the course of
decades of watching what happens to
humanity as people have hope lose hope
thoughts ideas oh it's just great
but of course Total Recall 19 what 1989
the original Schwarzenegger is just
perfection interstellar Minority Report
Scanner Darkly
the Star Wars although that's almost
more of a space opera than been science
fiction I just watched the original
matrix again bla bla bla bla bla thank
you guys oh I didn't sign the the silver
one give me that pen again here's the
silver one the one
the one silver copy don't burn this book
someone at premier collectables dot-com
/ Ruben is going to get this this is
literally the only one with the special
silver pen someone will get it I'm going
to mix it up in the stack of books right
now
Oh Claude you want in on this I'd almost
got in on this all right thank you guys
this was a long time coming to get to
today but I just I appreciate your
support and you guys filled me up with
enough of the the confidence in the love
and everything else to put my thoughts
out there and when I stand up for you I
know you guys are standing up for me
this is just the beginning again I don't
know how we always end up just at the
beginning again but here we are so thank
you have a great day everybody and I'll
see ya when I see ya